salut vous l'avez compris aujourd'hui on
va parler d'expérience qui ont été faits
sur le principe de la psychologie pour
découvrir des choses des grandes
théories les mettre en application ou
simplement les découvrir pour la
première fois et ça c'est intéressant
c'est tellement intéressante je me suis
dit qu'on allait en faire une vidéo mais
en fait ça vous le savez pas ce que vous
êtes déjà dedans
alors c'est parti loïc génériques
[Musique]
je vais vous parler exactement de cette
expérience et des théories qui en ont
découlé et puis j'en ai d'autres sous le
coude alors si ça ça vous plaît si ça
vous stimulez si vous dit [ __ ] j'en ai
bien voulu un peu plus vous me le dirait
dans les commentaires je vais pas faire
un sondage pour ça mais si je vois qu'il
ya masse personnes qui sont intéressés
et que la vidéo aussi a fait un peu de
vue j'en ferai une deuxième voire une
troisième et peut-être même que dans dix
ans je ferais que ça tellement ça vous
aura plu
[Musique]
une première expérience dont nous allons
parler c'est l'expérience qui avait mis
en place filigrane ce qui a donné
l'expression et la théorie de l'erreur
fondamentale d'attribution l'attribution
est un processus psychologique qui met
en perspective la cause et l'effet et
qui les réunit et qui les met en parler
tu vois et donc l'expérience café lire
os c'est de faire lire un texte à des
gens mais un texte avec des propos très
controversés et il observé et l'étudier
la réaction des personnes vis-à-vis de
la personne qui lisait le texte en fait
celle qui ne savaient pas que ce texte
n'avait pas été préparé par lui qui ne
faisait que le lire avec une très
mauvaise opinion sur cette personne mais
c'est là où ça devient intéressant c'est
que même les personnes qui savaient
qu'il ne faisait que lire un texte qu'il
n'était pas de lui mais il était obligé
de le faire avec quand même une mauvaise
opinion et le tenait en partie pour
responsable de ce que racontait le texte
et c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est en
fait ça vient à cause de presse que
l'averse de l'erreur fondamentale
d'attribution qui fait que quand des
choses nous arrive à nous c'est toujours
le fait de circonstances extérieures
psychologiquement parlant alors que
quand cette même chose arrive à
quelqu'un d'autre on en tient pour
entièrement responsable
l'exemple très classique on utilise pour
ça c'est de dire désolé je suis en
retard ce matin est ce que vraiment mon
réveil a pas sonné et en plus je me suis
couché tard parce qu'il fait du bruit à
peut-être chez moi peut être
complètement la vérité alors que si
quelqu'un arrive en retard pour vous
voir vous allez avoir plutôt tendance à
dire que c'est de sa faute en fait en
[ __ ] on ne peut pas te faire confiance
en fait toi tu es toujours à la bourre
de toute manière et vous allez lui en
vouloir à lui personnellement sans
prendre en compte les facteurs
extérieurs
c'est intéressant parce que grâce à
cette expérience on peut tenir compte de
ce biais là qu'on a instantanément pour
essayer de lutter contre et s'améliorer
un peu
[Musique]
l'expérience numéro deux à nous vient de
1956 par le psychologue américain george
miller
vous allez essayer de faire un peu comme
lui proposait à l'époque vous allez
essayer de retenir rapidement cette
phrase ici le tout ces lettres là à les
y retenir ça le plus vite possible
stop bon c'était pas facile et pourtant
si vous aviez vu ce qu'on a mis
secrètement à l'intérieur vous l'auriez
retenue en fait c'était juste
ubs le service postal bmw la bagnole cia
donc la cia et à la fin de loïc s'est
même intercalé à la toute fin et si je
vous avais dit ça dès le départ si vous
l'aviez vu aussi dès le départ ou si on
avait mis des points au début vous
l'auriez retenu instantanément parce que
c'est que quatre grosses informations à
retenir et c'est ça qui a essayé de
démontrer george miller en 56 c'est que
le cerveau humain dans sa mémoire de
travail n'arrive pas à retenir plus de
cette chose
en moyenne ce que ce soit des mots des
images des notes de musique la liste de
courses ce qu'on veut en général ces
sept
et c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'on divise
les choses qu'on l'ait subdivise par
plus gros paquet comme on le fait pour
les numéros de téléphone on retient pas
dix chiffres on les retient en fait part
par groupe de deux donc on retient déjà
que 5,1 formation et là c'est beaucoup
plus simple son élève sydney smith a lui
réussi l'exploit de retenir 40 noms
binaire en aléatoire on lui a présenté
une suite aléatoire de 1 à 0 il a retenu
ça et après il a expliqué qu'ils avaient
tous groupés par lot de huit ça fait
plus que cinq lots à retenir il avait
trouvé une petite méthode mnémotechnique
pour que sa forme des mots les suites
2-0 et 2-1 sa forme des mots est comme
ça il a retenu et c'est vrai que c'est
rare chaque tout c'est à dire que si on
divise un discours en partie ou un cours
pour ceux qui sont en cours en partie on
retient mieux on retient les chansons
par par rim de 2 et après par par couple
est parent aux freins et ensuite
l'ensemble donc grâce à george miller
on sait qu'il faut absolument regroupés
en dessous de 7 pour pouvoir bien
retenir les choses
[Musique]
pour cette troisième expérience nous
allons parler de quelque chose qui a été
fait en 1995 une étude très intéressante
qui a été fait avec plusieurs critères
la première chose qu'ils ont fait c'est
de demander tout un groupe de personnes
noires de pau que de remplir un test
d'intelligent et ils ont pris aussi une
partie de ces personnes là à qu'ils ont
dit que c'était un test pour voir un thé
pas vraiment un test d'ailleurs c'était
une étude pour voir comment réfléchissez
les gens quand il voulait résoudre un
problème toutes les personnes qui ont
pensé faire un test juste pour résoudre
les problèmes ont eu des meilleures
notes que les personnes qui ont eu le
même test mais qui pensait faire un test
d'intelligence sur elle même ça
s'appelle la menace du stéréotype
en gros quand toute ta vie tu as été
brimés par des choses pour ton caractère
de genre ou d'orientation sexuelle ou de
couleur de peau tu vas faire en sorte
que ce stéréotype s'autoproclame ils
sont allés plus loin dans les études par
exemple quand une femme joue contre un
ordinateur ou à un autre être humain
derrière et qu'elle pense que c'est un
homme
elle joue un peu plus mal parce que l ce
taux dévalorise de la même manière un
schizophrène va être beaucoup plus
maladroit s'ils pensent que les autres
personnes dans la pièce sont au courant
du fait qu'il est schizophrène en gros
la menace du stéréotype c'est par peur
de confirmer aux autres l'a priori et le
stéréotype qu'ils ont sur vous et bien
en fait vous êtes moins confiants et du
coup vous auto réaliser les choses dont
vous aviez peur dance et un peu pervers
quand même
[Musique]
la catherine étude s'est passé dans une
prison une fausse prison le psychologue
philip zimbardo avait un jour demandé à
des étudiants qui voudraient être
volontaires pour des études etc
alpha sow remplir des papiers experts
quelque temps après il fait arrêté douze
de ces étudiants-là par la police locale
qui les amène directement une prison ce
alors à dire ce que c'était et c'est si
les autres chaînes et kylie kylie
descend directement au sous sol ensuite
il demande à 12 personnes qui étaient
volontaires aussi pour les études qui
proposait au départ de se faire engager
pour être surveillant mathon externe les
douze personnes qui l'a recruté n'avait
rien dans leur profil psychologique de
de blizzard ou d'un ce tabou de cette
écoute choses comme ça et au contraire
que c'était des personnes qui a respecté
la loi qui était plutôt cool tu vois il
les a engagés
l'expérience devait durer deux semaines
elle s'est arrêtée au bout de six jours
pourquoi parce que les détenus étaient
dans un état assez extrêmes d'urgence en
fait de besoins psychologiques voire
médicaux parce qu'un tiers dont quatre
des douze surveillants avaient révélé un
comportement sadique et d'une manière
générale et deux surveillants s'était
montré plutôt à tendance sadique plutôt
injuste plutôt trop sévère et c'est donc
six jours au lieu de 12
il a fallu interrompre ça ça s'appelle
la prison de zimbardo aujourd'hui cette
expérience psychologique et elle révèle
vraiment que dans certaines
circonstances
sous certains ordres dans une certaine
situation on peut perdre complètement
ses valeurs initiales face c'est même
pas de l'obéissance à c'est une
situation plus que de lever licence
l'obéissance et plus l'expérience de
milgram d'ailleurs mais celle de
zimbardo elle montre plus plutôt que le
contexte la situation et la manière dont
se déroulent les choses peut faire qu'on
a un changement dans notre comportement
et nos valeurs et c'est intéressant
aussi pour comprendre un peu mieux
l'histoire
[Musique]
en cinquième on va parler de ce qu avait
constaté henri béchère durant la seconde
guerre mondiale c'était un anesthésiste
et c'est à lui qu'on doit la première
découverte de l'effet placebo
donc l'effet placebo c'est le fait de
prendre un médicament qui n'en est pas
un qui est juste du sucre et de l'eau et
de ressentir quand même des effets
bénéfiques lui il s'en est rendu compte
quand il s'est aperçu que les soldats
qui étaient blessés qui allait rentrer
chez eux souffraient moins que d'autres
soldats qui étaient moins blessés et
qu'ils allaient pas rentrer chez eux
et en fait il s'est dit ok
l'anticipation fait qu'ils prennent
leurs blessures pour une bonne chose
et apparemment ils se sentent mieux par
rapport à ça des expériences pour
comprendre cette psychologie un petit
peu particulières ont été faites et
aujourd'hui par exemple tous les labos
de pharmacies doivent tester en double
aveugle son appel en double aveugle
c'est à dire d'un côté un placebo et
d'un côté le vrai médicament mais
personne ne sait ce qu'il prend ça
permet de constater si c'est un
médicament qui a un effet placebo de
base ou s'il a vraiment des choses qui
sont actives et qui fonctionne à
l'intérieur et en faisant ça on s'est
aperçu d'autres choses dont on parle
assez rarement et c'est pour ça que je
me suis dit si t'es cool d'apporter
cette réflexion ici pour qu'un
médicament soit vraiment efficace il
faut que la personne
elles sont au courant qu'elle prenne ce
médicament et qu'elles soient au courant
de ce que le médicament va faire ou
guérir chez elle si la personne prend un
médicament et qu'elle ne sait pas par
exemple sur un lit d'hôpital en
perfusion et bien le médicament aura
moins d'effet et ça c'est pas que l'efsf
les placebos qui se passe dans la tête
parce qu'on on a tendance à dire l'effet
placebo c'est que psychologique pas du
tout ça va aussi déclenché dans le
cerveau quelque chose de très concret
qui sont des antalgiques cérébraux vers
le cerveau qui fabrique ses propres
antalgiques des opioïdes qui vont
soulager du coup la douleur mais ça il
le fait par anticipation
parce qu'il sait qu'il est en train de
se faire traiter donc l'effet placebo
c'est un peu plus complexe qu'il n'y
paraît c'était cool d'en parler
[Musique]
la prochaine expérience c'est le point
de départ ces collines chéri qui en 1950
a démontré que l'oreille savait
distinguer des sons dans la masse pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir filtrer en fait
juste une information parmi toutes les
autres ok en gros quand vous êtes dans
une soirée genre vous êtes dans un bar
il ya du bruit de partout et pourtant
vous parler peut-être avec quelqu'un qui
à l'autre bout de la table et vous
suivez votre conversation comme si tout
le brouhaha autour n'existait pas et
comme si c'était un peu un tas de son
mais qui n'avait pas trop de sens en
fait c est alors que c'est très clair ce
que l'autre vous dit du coup en 1958
donald pro demande a voulu aller un
petit peu plus loin en menant des
expériences un peu plus complexe parce
que la majorité des psychologues de
l'époque penser que le cerveau ne
savaient pas traiter plusieurs flux
d'informations en même temps et que
hockey y avait peut-être un filtre comme
ça mais ce filtre était unie qu'il
pouvait pas traiter deux informations en
même temps et lui il a démontré
l'inversé en fait c'est très simple il
demanda des participants de venir
il a remis un casque sur les oreilles
mais en fait c'est un double casque il
entendait des suites de chiffres de
chaque côté genre 314 un côté 628 de
l'autre mais tout ça en simultané et
malgré le fait que ce soit en simultané
il savait dissocier les deux chiffres et
ils pouvaient les notés ou voulait
répéter au fur et à mesure
tant que les informations elle reste
simple le cerveau peut avoir plusieurs
filtres en même temps et et les écoutait
les dissocier dès que ça devient un
petit peu complexe et c'est ce qu'a fait
donald de broadband en 58 après il a
accéléré le truc et l'a rendu les
informations plus complexes et là il ya
ce qu'on appelle le filtre debreu de
bandes qui se met en place et qui fait
qu'on arrive à se concentrer que sur un
seul et qu'on occulte complètement
l'autre on le perçoit
mais on ne le comprend pas comme quand
on parle avec quelqu'un dans une soirée
où des fois vous savez vous avez une
conversation et en même temps vous
saisissez an ou deux mots très simples
parce que ça vous intéresse sur le côté
c'est le filtre de bruit de bottes
[Musique]
il nous reste plus qu'une seule
expérience je voulais vous parler de
l'hypothèse de sapir worf il est parti
d'un principe très simple les eskimos
ont plus d'une centaine de mots pour
désigner des neiges différentes qu'on
n'est même pas capable de percevoir
mais comme la vidéo elle commence à être
un petit peu longue pour ce genre de
vidéo je vois contrer ça sur mon
instagram sur lequel vous pouvez me
rejoindre et si ça vous intéresse pas
instagram ne stressez pas j'en parlerai
un jour sur la chaîne mais en attendant
je vais le faire en story 2 aujourd'hui
comme ça vous pourrez le revoir ou en
vidéo rend dur si vous ne connaissiez
pas je m'appelle fabien olicard vous
pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne c'est
gratuit et vous pouvez activer la cloche
comme ça vous savez que les autres
vidéos elles sortent
vous pouvez cliquer cette vidéo pensez à
me dire si vous voulez un épisode 2
voilà puisque si vous voulez pas cessé
d'en faire un deuxième monsieur vous
voulez j'en fais un deuxième est ici je
vous mets deux autres vidéos qui peuvent
vous intéresser ça c'est une vidéo sur
l'effet mandela qui fait qu'on a
l'impression que le passé a été modifié
et ça c'est une vidéo sur l'effet dorian
gray qui dit que potentiellement notre
prénom une autre signe astrologique
peuvent nous influencer mais
scientifiquement parlant reste assez
passionnant à très bientôt cha